[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de Parlement
Hebdo l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité de la semaine au Parlement
et cette semaine sur ce plateau nous
accueillons Pierre-Henri Dumont bonjour
vous êtes députés les républicains du
pas decalais on va revoir avec vous ce
qui fait le débat au Parlement et à la
une cette semaine l'Assemblée nationale
adopte le projet de loi pour le plein
emploi désormais ma les bénéficiaires du
RSA devront réaliser 15 Hees d'activité
par semaine pour toucher leur allocation
le président de la République a dessiné
les contour de sa réforme de la
Constitution il est prêt à élargir le
champ du référendum on verra ce qu'en
pensent les sénateurs qui jouent un rôle
crucial dans toute révision
constitutionnelle et puis le sujet des
punaises de lis s'invite à l'Assemblée
nationale la France insoumise dénonce la
réaction tardive du Gouvernement sur ce
problème sanitaire qui gâche la vie de
nombreux
Français l'assemblée nation a donc
adopté mardi 4 octobre la loi elle a
plutôt achevé le débat sur la loi
baptisée pour le plein emploi le texte
sera adopté lors d'un vote solennel le
10 octobre prochain une mesure est au
cœur de ce texte le RSA sous conditions
retour en séance avec Elsa
mondingava c'est le point le plus
débattu du projet de loi sur le plein
emploi la réforme du RSA le revenu de
solidarité active le gouvernement veut
instaurer des contrepartie au versement
de cette allocation quand on dit
solidarité active ça veut dire activité
et ce que nous faisons là c'est au
contraire investir pour faire en sorte
que l'accompagnement soit présent et que
l'insertion soit présente moi je ne me
résous pas et je ne me résoudrai jamais
à ce que des hommes et des femmes dans
notre pays soient condamnés au RSA
pendant des dizaines des années et
parfois même des dizaines d'années et ce
que nous faisons c'est de mettre en
place un parcours les bénéficiaires
devront signer un contrat d'engagement
réciproque un amendement proposé par la
droite et voté par la majorité impose 15
he d'activité
hebdomadaire une obligation dont
pourront être exemptés les parents
isolés ou les allocataires porteurs de
handicap nous pensons que face au RSA il
y a des contreparties c'est 15h c'est
quoi ce sont 15 he d'accompagnement de
formation de stage à la fois
d'accompagnement professionnel et social
c'est pas l'un ou l'autre ce sont les
deux la gauche dénonce une mesure qui
stigmatise les plus précaires
avec cette idée que au fond celles et
ceux qui sont RSA sont des feignants et
qu'il faut les mettre d'urgence au
travail pour un revenu je le rappelle un
revenu qui est de 600 de 604 € le texte
prévoit aussi un nouveau régime de
sanction en cas de non respect des
engagements en France près d'1,9
millions de foyers sont à locataire du
RSA pieren dum si la loi voter donc
mardi prochain à l'Assemblée 15 he
d'activité seront obligatoires par
semaine pour pouvoir toucher le RSA
est-ce que ce n'est pas tout de même
stigmatisant à l'encontre des
bénéficiaires qui parfois n'ont pas
d'autre choix que d'être au RSA non mais
vous rigolez ce qui est stigmatisant
smatisant pardon c'est de faire de la
fausse solidarité comme vient de le
proposer la gauche et la France
insoumise la fausse solidarité c'est
quoi c'est d'imaginer qu'on donne 607 €
à des personnes et qu'on s'en occupe
plus moi je préfère que des gens
reprennent confiance en eux puissent
avoir le pied à l'étrier puissent
reprendre une petite activité il s'agit
pas d'avoir du travail déguisé il s'agit
de les aider à remplir un CV une lettre
de motivation parfois leur donner une
petite activité qui serait par exemple
d'accompagner des enfants à l'écool le
matin d'aider dans les collectivités
c'est au final redonner confiance à des
personnes qui sont très éloignées de
l'emploi vous savez il y a un il y a que
un/ers des allocataires du RSA qui à
l'issue de 7 ans dans le RSA sortent du
dispositif est-ce que vous trouvez ça
normal non ce n'est absolument pas
normal d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons des très grands besoins de main
d'œuvre parfois il faut trouver le petit
moment déclencheur le moment déclencheur
c'est redonner confiance aux
allocataires du RSA leur dire qu'ils
sont utiles à la société vous savez dans
la commune dont j'étais maire Marcon
calisi j'ai mis obligatoirement des
heures de bénévola dans le Pas de calé
j'ai mis obligatoirement des heures de
bénévola pour toutes les personnes qui
bénéficient d'une aide de la commune on
a eu 80 % de sorties positiv vers
l'emploi ou la for c'est donc des
dispositifs qui fonctionnent parce qu'on
fait confiance aux gens et qu'on leur
redonne confiance en eux vous parlez de
besoin de main d'œuvre ça veut dire que
vous assumez que c'est bénéficiaires du
RSA pourrait répondre à ce besoin non
c'est absolument pas ce que j'ai dit je
dis qu'il y a des besoins de main
d'œuvre et que donc on ne comprendrait
pas qu'il y ait d'un côté simplement
un/ers des allocataire du RSA qui
sortent du RSA après 7 ans et que de
l'autre côté des entreprises n'arrivent
pas à recruter et que parfois il y a des
personnes qui sont très éloignées de
l'emploi qui n'arrivent pas à rentrer
même dans des dispositifs d'insertion et
c'est pour ça qu'on qu'on souhaite une
fois plus leur remettre le pied à
l'étrier ça s'agit pas de prendre des
allocataires du RSA pour compléter les
offres d'emploi manquantes il s'agit
simplement de les faire progresser petit
à petit vers le chemin de l'insertion du
travail les personnes qui sont très
éloignées de l'emploi elles rentreront
peut-être grâce à ce dispositif dans des
dispositifs d'aide d'accompagnement
d'association d'insertion les personnes
dans les associations d'insertion
arriveront peut-être ensuite
progressivement vers l'emploi et donc on
arrivera avec un cheminement positif qui
permettra de résoudre des problèmes
d'emploid et surtout surtout surtout de
sortir de la précarité on ne vit pas
avec 607 € alors oui mais on comprend
bien la philosophie sur le papier mais
est-ce que notre système actuel de
protection sociale encore lourdement
endetté a concrètement les moyens de
fournir ces 15 heures d'accompagnement
c'est quand même pas rien ça a été testé
dans plusieurs collectivités pas le même
dispositif mais un simili à ce
dispositif ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
et je vous le dis là où ça a été testé
il y a des retours extrêmement positifs
de la part évidemment des départements
qui portent cette mesure et qui ont
essayé cette mesure plutôt des
départements de droite d'ailleurs et
puis surtout les allocataires du RSA qui
retrouvent un travail qui retrouvent
confiance en eux et qui sont capables de
pouvoir à nouveau peut-être se rendre
utile la société et rendre fi les
enfants moi je je prends en mémoire une
personne qui était dans ma commune qui a
donné un coup de main lors d'une
brocante pour sécuriser la brocquante
dans le dispositif que j'avais mis en
place et il m'a dit vous savez à
l'époque j'étais j'étais encore maire
vous savez Monsieur le Maire euh moi je
pour la première fois mon fils était
fier il a dit regardez c'est mon papa en
passant devant lui donc il sécurisa la
Brocan donc c'est c'est également
important N'oubliez jamais ça alors
cette mesure à l'Assemblée nationale
elle fait l'objet d'une alliance entre
la majorité présidentielle et les
députés républicains puisque c'est un
amendement du député LR philippe Juvin
qui a été retenu finalement entre l'ELR
et la majorité présidentielle ce sont
les mêmes solutions qui sont proposées
pour cette question du chômage les
républicains c'est le parti des droits
et des devoirs nous avions toujours
proposé dans nos programmes électoraux
c'est c'est dans mon programme aux
élections législatives par exemple la
mise en place d'une contrepartie au
versement du RSA pas parce que c'est
quelque chose de nouveau mais c'est
quelque chose qui était imaginé depuis
la création du RSA mais qui n'avait
jamais été réellement mise en place donc
la majorité a décidé de nous rejoindre
sur ce point ça avait été mis en place
par les sénateurs ça avait été proposé
dans nos différents programmes
électorauuxx tant mieux ça prouve que
les républicains sont capables de
pouvoir faire des choses concrètes et si
on réussit à sortir des dizaines de
milliers de personnes du RSA ce sera une
excellente nouvelle pour ces person
initialement ce sont bien les sénateurs
LR qui avaient instauré dans le texte
ces 15hures d'activité est-ce que vous
vous êtes concerté vous députés ici avec
vos collègues de la Chambre haute c'est
c'est une proposition du parti c'est une
proposition des différents candidats à
l'élection présidentielles depuis de
nombreuses années des ça va plaire 15h
d'activité au sénateur c'est assez c'est
assoupli c'est les sénate estiment que
vous avez trop assoupli le dispositif
car cette durée de 15 heur d'activité
par semaine pourrait être réduite en
fonction du profil individuel qu'est-ce
que vous le dit on ta la réité c'est que
nous avons ex ça a été dit dans votre
reportage les personnes les parents
isolés qui ont des problèmes de garde
d'enfants les personnes en situation de
handicap et si on gardait la mesure
initiale dans le texte telle qu' était
sortie de la commission c'estàd la
volonté des députés de la majorité
associé aux voix de la gauche et du
rassemblement national qui s'est
complètement planqué durant ce débat où
ils n'ont pas pris position sur cette
sur cette mesure et je rappelle que les
députés du rassemblement national ont
voté avec la nupes pour empêcher voter
contre cet amendement et pour ne pas
avoir le les 15h donc il est quand même
passé alors la réalité c'est quoi c'est
que 15h peut-être que c'est pas assez
mais en tout cas c'est déjà un début et
que si on navait pas ce système de 15h
tel qu'il a été proposé par les députés
et les républicains il n' aurait rien eu
du tout je préfère avoir 15h que rien du
tout et avec un minimum en effet ça peut
être dégressive selon le profil de la
personne mais la position initiale du
gouvernement c'était qu'il n'y avait
vous pouvez faire zéro he dans le
contrat d'engagement nous que ce soit de
la formation que ce soit de
l'accompagnement que ce soit en effet un
petit travail il y aura ces 15 heures
qui sont mis en place et c'est déjà un
bon point alors cette semaine le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron a dessiné les contours de sa
prochaine révision de la Constitution il
a notamment défendu l'idée d'élargir les
thèmes que le Président de la République
pourrait soumettre à référendum alors
qu'on pense à les sénateurs qui auront
leur mots à dire pour faire adopter
cette révision constitutionnelle un
sujet de Samia de chir c'est une
promesse qui date de son premier
quinquena Emmanuel Macron veut réformer
la Constitution et notamment élargir le
champ du référendum très strictement
encadré par l'article 11 il ne peut
aujourd'hui porter que sur
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics la
politique économique et sociale ou la
ratification de traités internationaux
le président de la République veut
l'ouvrir à d'autres sujets il existe
encore des domaines importants pour la
vie de la nation qui échappent au champ
de l'article 11 de notre Constitution et
je souhaite que nous puissions trouver
collectivement les moyens de mener à son
terme ce chantier favorable à cet
élargissement la droite sénatoriale
réclame un engagement ferme du président
pour l'organisation d'un référendum sur
l'immigration Emmanuel Macron peut pas
nous balader pendant des mois comme il
peut s'apprêter à le faire si
parallèlement il ne s'engage pas
clairement à faire un référendum et nous
lui suggérons sur l'immigration mais les
centristes alliés de la droite au Sénat
ne sont pas favorables à l'élargissement
du référendum et encore moins sur
l'immigration je serai oui ou non à un
paquet complet sur des questions qui
sont liées aux filières
clandestines à la question
de du du du travail au régularisation et
voulez le faire comme ça par un paquet
qu'on qu'on lance au peuple en disant
oui ou non la gauche elle aussi opposée
à tout référendum sur l'immigration se
montre sceptique sur les annonces
d'Emmanuel Macron le président s'est dit
favorable à l'inscription de l'IVG dans
la Constitution promesse déjà formulée
le 8 mars dernier je ne compte plus le
nombre d'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron
sur la réforme constitutionnelle depuis
les 78 mois dans lequel dans lesquel il
dirige le pays donc voilà c'est une
nouvelle annonce qui s'inscrit dans une
forme de procrastination immigration
interruption volontaire de grossesse la
réforme de la Constitution voulu par
Emmanuel Macron baler des sujets
clivants des lignes rouges pour la
droite comme la gauche le président aura
bien du mal à faire adopter sa réforme
par le Parlement étape obligatoire pour
changer la constitution alors pieren les
républicains veulent élargir le champ du
référendum à l'immigration mais à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
les députés LR vous aurez une majorité
pour faire voter une telle mesure un
élargissement un référendum sur
l'immigration quelle majorité vous aurez
écoutez on verra déjà la proposition
constitutionnelle qui est mise sur la
table par le Président de la République
et par par le gouvernement nous on a
toujours été très clair nous estimons
que le champ de l'article 11 qui ouvre
le droit au référendum est beaucoup trop
limité et que donc il faut l'élargir à
tous les sujets l'immigration évidemment
mais pas que il faut qu'il y ait les
sujets de société qui puissent c'est
aussi être r trranché vous savez nous
sommes une famille gouliste général de
Goul n'a jamais eu peur du peuple
d'ailleurs il est parti il a quitté le
pouvoir à l'issue d'un référendum qu'il
avait perdu et donc nous estimons que
parfois quand les situations sont
bloquées il faut s'en remettre au peuple
parce que il y a des intérêts
particuliers au niveau du Parlement qui
empêchent de trancher des sujets
extrêmement majeurs l'immigration
évidemment premier chef on comprend bien
mais concrètement quelle question vous
pourriez poser au français vous allez
soumettre comme le disait votre collègue
du Sénat un paquet complet c'està- dire
tout le projet de loi immigration au
français le premier sujet c'est la
réforme constitutionnelle d'abord si on
ne peut pas faire de de référendum sur
l'immigration s'il n'y a pas une réforme
un changement de l'article 11 de la
Constitution donc l'urgence le point le
plus important c'est d'abord de réformer
la Constitution une fois que cela est
fait on verra les termes dans lesquels
la réforme constitutionnelle est
proposée par le gouvernement nous
pourrions soit par un référendum
d'initiative partagé soit directement
par une décision du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale présenter un
référendum sur l'immigration avec un
sujet en particulier qui est la
prédominance du droit national dans
cette matière migratoire sur le droit
européen parce qu'on l'a bien vu une
dernière décision de la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne l'a
malheureusement démontré aujourd'hui
nous ne sommes plus en possibilité de
d'imposer le pouvoir éégalien de savoir
qui entre qui se maintient qui doit
partir du territoire parce que un
ensemble de textes qui sont pas des
textes européens mais qui sont des
jurisprudences des différentes cours de
justice de l'Union européenne empêche le
pays notre pays de pouvoir appliquer une
politique migratoire qu'il désire donc
par référendum voulaz sortir des traités
européens sur les non nous voulons faire
ce qu'on appelle un optout c'est-à-dire
une adaptation du droit européen comme
il
existe ce qu'on pu faire les
Britanniques ce qu'on fait les
Néerlandais dans certains sujets en
particulier en terme de taxation ce que
font d'autres pays les Danois par
exemple qui ont exercé un tel système
sur des politiques migratoires sur
certains sujets et donc c'est quelque
chose qui existe qui n'a pas été mis en
France mais vous savez il faut que la
France impose un peu plus sa place dans
le concert des nations de l'Union
européenne moi je me souviens que quand
les intérêts vitaux de la France é était
en jeu au niveau de l'Union européenne
le général de Goul avait fait la
politique de la chaise vide en 1965
pendant 6 mois ça avait cert bloqué les
institutions mais au final on avait un
préservver le budget de la politique
agricole commune de maintenu le droit de
vetto sur les sujets les plus importants
on voit bien que quand on va au bras de
fer il est possible de pouvoir remporter
des sujets il y faut pas avoir une
destinée qui soit créée par les juges
européens qu'on reprenne de la
souveraineté d'une part aux état d'autre
part au peuple c'est au peuple de
décider et non pas à des gens qui ne
sont pas élus alors quand même on n'y
est pas pour pouvoir changer la
Constitution il faut il y a la procédure
est lourde il faut que les deux chambres
assemblée Sénat votent dans le même
terme vous croyez vraiment que ça peut
aboutir oui ça peut aboutir et on vous
parliez de la constitutionnalisation du
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse euh bon même c'est un sujet
qui en fait ne fait pas de débat en
France c'est un sujet sociétal un porté
des États-Unis aujourd'hui il y a pas
une seule formation politique représenté
à l'Assemblée nationale qui est contre
l'interruption volontaire de grossess vé
à l'assemée nationté voté à l'Assemblée
nationale mais on a trouvé un compromis
avec le Sénat la formulation qui est
celle de Philippe Bas au Sénat qui était
de dire de de la liberté de la femme de
mettre fin à sa grossesse c'est quelque
chose qui permettait de sécuriser
juridiquement le texte permettait
d'avoir un accord entre les républicains
ici à l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
donc on voit qu'en travaillant main dans
la main côte à côte il est possible de
pouvoir trouver des formulations parce
qu'il faut être très précis dans la
formulation de la réforme de la
Constitution parce que il y a après des
questions d'interprétation de la
Constitution qui est celle du Conseil
constitionnel et du juge administratif
et donc ça nécessite d'être extrêmement
précis on peut pas aller à la Vavie donc
ce sera en effet un travail d'écriture
extrêmement important mais j'ai toute
confiance dans nos collègues sénateurs
et puis ici mes collègues députés pour
trouver les meilleures formulations qui
laissent pas d'interprétation et pas de
possibilité pour les juges de tordre le
coup et le doigt du législateur qui a
écrit la réforme de la Constitution donc
pour vous il peut y avoir un consensus
sur cette inscription du droit à l'IVG
dans la constition je vous dis ça
dépendra de la réforme du package qui
sera présenté parce qu'il y a plusieurs
sujets qui ont été ouverts par le
Président de la République va pas faire
sujet par sujet ce sera un ensemble nous
nous sommes évidemment favorable à la
formulation que je viens de vous
exprimer qui était celle qui a été
présentée par le Sénat d' alors
l'élargissement du champ du référendum
c'est une demande de longue date du
rassemblement national et justement on
va écouter la réaction de Marine Le Pen
à ses annonces cette semaine du
président de la République
oui notre
Constitution est remarquable il faut
donc la préserver la protéger peut-être
d'ailleurs la reli de temps en temps
quand on est dirigeant parce que on
s'aperçoit que petit à petit on l'a un
petit peu vidé de cette puissance mais
elle peut-être améliorée et notamment
par la mise en œuvre du référendum
d'initiative
populaire qui est absent aujourd'hui je
pense aussi que la Constitution ne
devrait pouvoir être réformée que par
référendum alors justement parlons du
référendum d'initiative partagée entre
les parlementaires et les des citoyens
Emmanuel Macron souhaite faciliter le
recours à ce type de référendum
d'ailleurs il en avait déjà parlé après
la crise des gilets jaunes en 2019 mais
sans véritable concrétisation et l'an
dernier et bien le gouvernement n'était
pas favorable à un RIP sur la réforme
des retraites est-ce qu'il y a un double
discours du président sur cette question
du Rip ce qui est sûr c'est que ça a
bien arrangé le président de la
République qu' ait pas de référendum sur
les retraites ça c'est évident ceci
étant dit il faut que on fixe un cadre
qui soit un cadre général et qu'on
l'adapte pas par rapport aux événements
que on puisse développer le référendum
d'initiativ partagé c'est-à-dire
abaisser le seuil du nombre de
signataires nécessaires au niveau des
citoyens par exemple passer de 4 à 1
million le seuil c'est quelque chose qui
serait extrêmement positif le rip qui a
été celui qui a été le plus rcontré le
plus de succès c'est celui sur Aéroport
de Paris sur la privatisation d'Aéroport
de Paris mais qui avait obtenu plus d'un
million de signatures et donc c'est
quelque chose qui va à mon à mon avis
dans le bon sens là vous faisiez partie
des députés qu'on a qualifié de front ur
contre la réforme des retraites vous
regrettez qu'il n'y ait pas eu de RIP de
référendum sur la réforme des retraites
j'ai pas regrettter qu'il ait pas eu de
RIP enin pardon mais le sujet maintenant
c'est le sujet de la Constitution et ça
dépasse puisqu'on parle de loi
fondamentale ça dépasse les petite loi
don celle de la retraite qui impacte des
millions de Français certes mais on
parle ici de la réforme de la
Constitution il ne s'agit pas de faire
une réforme de la Constitution pour
répondre à tel ou tel besoin c'est ce
que j'exprimais sur la question de l'IVG
qui est un débat importé des États-Unis
mais il s'agit en fait de fixer un cadre
qui permettra à de régler l'ensemble des
problèmes s'il y a un nombre minimum de
signatur via le rip ou si en élargissant
le champ du référendum de l'article 11
il y a un sujet que nous désirons à
l'Assemblée nationale et ou au Sénat
être tranché par les citoyens qu'on
puisse le faire on va parler du sujet
des punaises de lit qui s'est invité
cette semaine à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est nuisible disparu dans les années
50 mais qui sont revenus he seer à la
panique dans le quotidien des Français
le gouvernement a été interpellé à
plusieurs reprises sur ce sujet
notamment par la présidente du groupe la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
Mathilde Panau qui a reproché à la
Premier ministre son inaction ces petits
insectes répandent le désespoir dans
notre pays faut-il attendre que Matignon
soit infester pour qu'enfin vous
réagissiez oui les punaises de lit sont
une angoisse pour nos concitoyens qui
craignent d'y être confronté c'est un
véritable calvaire pour ceux qui sont
touchés l'infestation d'un logement peut
devenir un enfer pour celles et ceux qui
y habitent et les solutions pour s'en
débarrasser peuvent être coûteuses et la
majorité présidentiel a engagé un
travail pour trouver des réponses de
long terme sur la détection
l'infestation et l'accompagnement des
personnes touché une réflexion qui
devrait pouvoir rassembler largement
dans cet hémicycle alors travaillons
ensemble trouvons des solutions ensemble
Pierre-Henry Dumont est-ce que pour vous
le gouvernement a sous-estimé la la
menace soudain des des punaises de lit
il faut trancher ce qui est de l'ordre
du réel et de la psychose déjà parce
qu'on a l'impression tous d'avoir des
punaises de lit chez soi depuis que le
sujet monte et est mise en en exerg dans
les médias la réalité c'est qu'il y a
souvent eu des punaises de lit on prend
des articles d' y a 5 ou 10 ans on voit
bien qu'il des lycée avait déjà à
l'époque étit fermé pour des raisons
d'infestation DEP comment vous expliquez
cette psychose cette le fait qu'on en
parle soudainement déjà il il y a des
aspects techniques hein c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des insecticides qui ont été
interdits il y a quelques années ensuite
on sait bien que funess de lit voyage
avec l'augmentation des mobilités des
migrations que ce soit celle de
voyageurs en particulier et que donc du
coup avec l'interdiction de
l'insecticide en question puis la
période covid qui a bloqué la plupart
des voyages on n' pas pu voir les effets
de l'interdiction de cet insecticide sur
la prolifération des punaises de lit
avant 2022 2023 c'est-à-dire qu'on est
qu'on est aujourd'hui en plein dedans
donc il a avant toute chose un travail
de cartographie des endroits où il y a
le plus de tunaises de lit il y a
ensuite une question de de prévention
c'est le point le plus important c'està
dire faire comprendre parce que c'est un
phénomène nouveau puisqueil y a une
prolifération extrêmement importante
dans certains endroits bah que quand on
achète des vêtements de seconde main il
faut vérifier que quand on voyage dans
les transports collectifs il faut faire
attention que il y a des des possibilité
de mettre par exemple des vêtements
fragiles au congélateur d'être un peu
technique pour tuer les les punaises de
lit donc voilà c'est une question de
prévention qui n'a pas été faite parce
qu'il y avait pas de voyage à un moment
où ça avait été normalement le pic de
l'explosion supposé et ensuite il y a la
question qui est la question de pouvoir
répondre aux attentes la question de je
vous dis de voir les outils pour pouvoir
les cartographier et la question du du
coût de la prise en charge de
l'éradication des foyers des punaises de
lit et là je suis pas certain que ça
doit passer par la loi il faut avec les
moyens être très agiles les ARS les
préfectures faire en sorte de pouvoir
travailler avec toutes les parties
prenantes pour rapidement éradiquer ce
fléo et puis aussi mettre fin un peu à
la psychose vous dis faire la différence
entre ce qui ressort réellement d'une
qui supp alors Pierre Henri Dumont en
tout cas dans ce débat devient politique
et d'ailleurs le président du groupe LR
à l'Assemblée national Olivier marlex a
dit que oui il y avait un sujet sur le
lien entre camp de réfugié et Puna de
lit je le cite ne soyons pas tartuf
est-ce que c'est propos vous ont gêné ce
qui est sûr je vous l'ai dit c'est que
les punaes de lit prolifèrent en raison
des migrations c'està-dire des
déplacements de population et de la
promiscuité c'està-dire que quand vous
avez des espaces clos encombrés dans les
prisons par par exemple on voit qu'il
peut y avoir des des résurgences dans
des appartements qui sont des petits
appartements avec des personnes qui
vivent à 4 5 6 dans une vingtaine de
mètres carrés il y a un facteur plus
favorable à la prolifération et que les
populations immigrées qui arrivent en
France de façon régulière ou irrégulière
ont plutôt tendance c'est les chiffres
et c'est les statistiques qui prouvent
aller dans des endroits où les loyers
sont plus faibles parce que c'est là où
vivent leur famille leurs amis les
personnes qui viennent de leur pays et
donc ont plutôt tendance à rajouter et à
vivre dans des espaces qui sont des
espaces de forte promiscuit mais donc
vous faites un lien indirect entre
assume
assumez il y a à mon sens un lien
indirect c'est pas le facteur
déterminant premier le facteur premier
c'est évidemment celui des voyages celui
des ceux qui prennent le train ceux qui
prennent les transports en commun de
ceux qui partent à l'étranger ceux qui
vont dans les chambres d'autel qui
peuvent ramener il y a un lien qui
existe mais qui sur la question
migratoire mais qui n'est pas le lien
direct essentiel mais est-ce que ça vous
a quand même choqué ces propos de dire
il y a un
sujetit il y a il y a un sujet mais
c'est pas le sujet principal je vous ai
répondu non alors en tout cas il y a une
question qui se pose notamment sur
l'image de la France à l'internationale
on voit que la presse étrangère s'empare
du sujet il peut y avoir des inquiétudes
sur cette image à l'internationale à 10
mois des Jeux Olympiques ah ben c'est
évident parce qu'en plus on est sur un
sujet qui fait les chougraas des
commentateurs des imitateurs vous
regardez le tight show de Jimmy Fallon
aux États-Unis qui a caricaturé le
président Macron en roi des punaises de
l bon voilà on est sur un sujet qui est
le sujet de la place du rayonnement de
la France à l'internationale avant les
Jeux Olympiques pendant la Coupe du
monde de rugby c'est évidemment une
publicité qui n'est pas très bonne qui
aurait pu qui aurait dû être anticipée
par le gouvernement et qui n'a pas
écouté les alertes qui avaiit été lancé
par différents groupes politiques dont
le nôtre alors on va se projeter sur la
semaine prochaine très rapidement à
l'Assemblée nationale le 12 octobre
prochain les députés RN vont porter dans
l'hémicycle une proposition de loi qui
prévoit notamment de suspendre des
allocations familiales pour les parents
d'enfants délinquants ou criminels
est-ce que vous députés LR vous êtes
prêt à voter ce texte évid nous allons
voter pour une raison qui est très
simple vous l'assumez de voter on va le
simple parce que c'est notre texte ils
ont copierécollé quasiment la
proposition de loi de Jean-Louis Thierot
qui est députés les républicains ils ont
repris le principe d'une proposition de
loi qui avait été adoptée mise en œuvre
par erriic soti qui était la suspension
des allocations familiales des parents
des enfants absentéistes à l'école et
donc là on est sur la question des la
suspension des allocations familiales
pour les parents des enfants délinquants
je vous dis ça a été présenté par
Jean-Lou cot lors d'une proposition de
loi il y a plusieurs mois ils ont repris
le stylo en adoptant un pe en l'
adaptant un petit peu nous aurons des
amendements pour revenir à la version
originale qui était présentée par les
députés les républicains mais ce serait
complètement idiot de ne pas voter un
texte qui a été écrit d'abord par les
députés et les républicains sous
prétexte qu'il a été repris par tel ou
tel groupe merci beaucoup Pierre-Henri
duond c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir été notre invité merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi et on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine très bonne suite de
[Musique]
programme